it's day four of the startup
entrepreneur tour six of us are in the
RV 35 states 10,000 miles all across the
country
we already went to Palmdale it was about
300 people there then we went to
Bakersfield 300 something people there
Ventura 3 and there's something people
there now we're off to just got done
visiting Rich Dad Poor Dad headquarters
spent a couple hours with Robert
Kiyosaki great time great conversation
that interview will be coming out here
soon I'll put the link on the bottom
when it comes out and we are now off to
New Mexico and all we're talking about
is why to become an entrepreneur that's
what it's been all about for the last
four days and we got 26 more days to go
got my buddy here Mario working team
driving one of our drivers back he is
getting some R&R before his turn comes
but anyways let me let me one of the
conversations that came up Marv if you
want to hold this one of the
conversations that came up on the tour
was white to become an entrepreneur and
a lot of times we talk about the common
reasons of why to become an entrepreneur
but I think the deeper reasons are the
real reasons why I believe everybody
ought to become an entrepreneur whether
it's five hours a week ten hours a week
40 hours a week or if you want to be a
serial entrepreneur running businesses
nationwide international traveling
influence and all that's up that's fine
but I believe 100% of people ought to
become an entrepreneur so the common
reasons we constantly hear about the
common reasons what are the common
reasons you ought to become an
entrepreneur because you will have tax
benefits true a lot of tax benefits
there needs to be tax incentives the
reason why there's tax incentives when
some people say you know entrepreneurs
have all these tax incentives they ought
to have tax incentives because if
there's not an incentive to start a
business then people won't start
businesses and if we don't start
businesses then we don't have jobs so
there's got to be tax incentives for
people who start businesses that's why
there's tax and
some people say it's travel I've had a
luxury of traveling all over the world
and as becoming an entrepreneur I've
been all over the world
Croatia Santorini Athens my synovium
Ennis Italy Guatemala least wanna deport
d'Ivoire to corner Hawaii Maui st.
Maarten Caribbean Cayman Islands
Portugal Spain NASCAR races Disney World
Kentucky Derby Superbowl Pebble Beach
we're going to Dubai in a couple of
weeks we just got back from st. Regis
Aspen we were in Tuscany we Italy we've
stayed at Cinque Terre all over the
place you get to travel a lot and it's
absolutely a big part of it some say for
retirement I won't have a lot of money
in cities I don't have a lot of money
great that's a common reason some say
quality time with family great points
some people want to run a business with
families some don't want to run a
business with family some want to run a
business and build something with their
life because they don't want to have
wife doing one job and husband doing
another job they want to both be
building something together right some
say I want to become an entrepreneur
because I want a nice car no problem you
ought to get the nice cars they build
themselves a nice car some say I want to
become an entrepreneur because I won
nice watches nice jewelry I'm gonna live
in a big house I want to put big parties
together big you know celebrity parties
to get a private parties like gatsby did
and invite you know 500 people and put
the most incredible luxurious parties
together no prompts another reason to
become an entrepreneur I want to be in
charge of my life control my life make
as much money out as much as I want to
make great all of that is great but I
don't think those are the most important
reasons why you ought to become an
entrepreneur I will give you a deeper
reasons why we ought to become
entrepreneurs you see you ever heard the
saying where people say when you swim
you know how you're going lift weights
and you're you know I used to be a
bodybuilder so when you're lifting
weights and you're competing you build
your bus do you build your body legs
calves shoulders traps chests whatever
but then they say you know swimming
develops certain muscles that no other
weight or machine can ever develop
swimming just swimming along you can't
go to the gym and develop the muscle of
swimming as swimmer develops if you look
at the body of a body
and if you look at the body of Michael
Phelps a swimmer it's complete different
a bodybuilders body will never develop
like a body of a swimmer because the
swimmers body is developing certain
muscles that the body builders never
touching so what does that have to do
with anything well when you become an
entrepreneur you develop a certain
muscles that you never thought you had
you will never know that muscle unless
you become an entrepreneur it's when you
become one you Jack couldn't believe I'm
good at this I can't believe I'm so good
at leading people I'm so good at solving
issues I'm so good at you know
multitasking some people have a hard
time with that I'm so good at not
panicking when crisis happens I'm so
good at being calm I never knew I could
do this I never knew I could you know be
so good at teaching people I never
thought I was a good teacher I never
thought it was a good leader you you'll
learn certain things that the industry
that the skill of becoming an
entrepreneur does but here's a deeper
reasons here should be for reasons she
think about happiness everybody in the
world whatever activity we do doesn't
matter whether you like like Hispanic
Asian Chinese a middle-eastern tall
short skinny it doesn't matter what
educated uneducated you you like the
Lakers you like the Clippers it's
irrelevant every single body that's
every single thing with the purpose of
having a final product which is to
become happy we all do everything to
become happy we want to be happy you
know we want to live a fulfilling life
we want to be fulfilled we want to live
a meaningful life and a lot of times
people seek happiness through temporary
highs that temporary highs have many
different names for it could be alcohol
it could be drugs and we have many forms
of drugs and you know a pot it could be
ecstasy it could be cocaine it could be
they're all over the place there's so
many of them people think hey if I use
this I'm going to be happy but to me
that the the most important part about
happiness is the lifespan of the
hi the lifespan of that hi how long does
a high lasts and the longest lifespan of
highs are natural highs so what makes us
happy think about this
you ever babysat somebody before I don't
know if you have I have babysat somebody
for about the first 15-20 minutes you
just having so much fun this kid is so
cute this kid is so great and then all
of a sudden happens to the kid the kid
poops and we say I don't want to babysit
this kid anymore right and we give it
away and we say here you go the kids
coming back to you we ever taking care
of your own kid think about this for a
second
what happens when our kids food no
problem what happens when your kids do
whatever they did no problem why do we
get married and have kids and build a
family because creating is very
important to us when we create it
produces happiness fulfillment and a
possibility of living a meaningful life
every parent wants their kids to one day
say my mother changed my life my father
changed my life because it's important
to us to live a meaningful meaningful
life and a fulfilled life by living a
legacy to our it's important to us and
if you look at anybody that's bitter not
happy you will usually see somebody
that's no longer creative no longer
producing no longer making something we
like finishing puzzles because we
created the puzzle I saw a TEDx video
send by a friend the other day about the
man talking about how we like to produce
and make things at IKEA because we like
to go to Ikea and buy IKEA products
because we make the product and 176
pieces you sit there and by the time the
products over would you say oh my
goodness this was incredible you feel
good I built that furniture I built that
cabin and I build that bit it feels good
when we create when you and I create we
feel good we feel very very good every
time we create something the second
thing that's very important to us that
has to be logical nor chef it's
community we have a need for community
community is very important to us if you
think about Facebook if you think about
Twitter if you think about Instagram
snapchat if you think about any YouTube
any one of these things the reason why
people get this endorphins this high is
because we belong to a community let me
check my phone to see will like my page
let me check my phone to see how many
Instagram likes I got well let me check
my phone see Mary what comments you
posted because it's a community because
we need to belong to community when you
build a family you get married you have
two families that come together it's a
community kids typically tend to bring
grandparents together think about how
many times grandparents who used to be
married for many years that got a
divorce and they haven't spoken for 20
years and then boom there's a grandchild
everybody comes together so creating a
child brings the community back together
and the last one is the sense of
ownership sense of ownership to us is
very important we have to own things we
like to own homes we like to own our car
we say that's my lawn that's my house
that's my car that's my family that's my
son that's my child that's my that's
mine I created we have to have a sense
of ownership and when you become an
entrepreneur as as great as the common
reasons are and that's great
as phenomenal two common reasons are on
all the tax freedom money great the
deeper reasons that lead to the emotion
we all want of happiness fulfillment and
a meaningful life comes when we create
and we're part of a community of other
entrepreneurs that are also creating
jobs creating a product producing
something that's providing value for
someone else that they're willing to pay
for and you have a sense of ownership
when you're an entrepreneur you own a
part of the business you own the company
you and other people own this thing we
built it together that's one of the most
incredible natural highs that has the
longest possibility of the longest
lifespan outside of family when you
build a community when you build a
business when you create something so
you know the the message every single
city we're going to people are coming up
to us and saying I've never thought
about entrepreneurship that way before
I've never thought about why I ought to
become an entrepreneur and create
something I've been
bitter lately I've been a little bit
unhappy lately and I notice I'm not
creating anything I say go out there and
become an entrepreneur create something
and it resonates so I challenged you if
you're already an entrepreneur great
keep creating more keep producing more
keep expanding your community but also
inspire other people to also do the same
and if you're somebody that's watching
this and you're saying you know I've
been happy lately but try creating
something and look what happened
go try getting involved with the
community and look what happened go
start a business with somebody get
involved with a community of business
owners entrepreneurs join their ventures
get involved with their businesses not
only will you grow a lot but all of a
sudden you'll hear a lot of your friends
and family saying you've changed it
sounds like you joined something it's
like you're almost like too happy what
happens you know you're finally
experiencing happiness fulfillment and a
meaningful life that's why everybody
ought to become an entrepreneur anyways
imma let you go because I need to see if
the drivers falling asleep or not on us
here before we get to New Mexico so if
you got thoughts questions comment on
the bottom if not be sure to subscribe
to this channel and visit my website if
you haven't visited my new website
wwlp.com it's my message to week to you
take care talk to you soon